(logo whooshing)
- And about seven minutes in I said,
this is gonna change my life, straight up.
(plane engine revving)
(people applauding)
You got your perspective.
(audience applause)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
- Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Yeah.
- Did I pronounce that correctly?
- I think you did a good job.
- Gary, thank you for
joining us, appreciate it.
- Men I really appreciate your time,
and I'm excited to be here.
- Yeah, for sure.
So let's jump right into it.
Our shows a little different
because you know, we break
down the business models.
We break down entrepreneur's success,
like when we had Mark Cuban on.
Shout out to Mark.
We asked him about his deal
that he did when he sold it,
and then he hedged the stock
and he gave a great explanation.
So a lot of people might, or
they may, or they may not,
know your story they heard the story
about you started in the wine business,
your family's wine business, right?
And in the late nineties,
and turned it from
three million operation,
to I believe a $60 million operation.
And you did it.
It was early in the, we
call it digital real estate.
And first wine e-commerce platform.
So can you talk about that?
How you had the foresight,
and how you actually transitioned that,
and how you was early on
to the e-commerce phase?
- Timing's incredible about this.
I just literally, literally
got off the phone,
with my six best buds from college.
Shout out to 301, to spot, Ms. Iraq,
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
Dustin LA, Tokyo, Joe, and Glenn.
It was there in Mount Ida
College in Newton Mass in 1995.
When Keep from Maine,
and we had nicknames for everybody.
Pete from Maine, said
come and check this out.
And I heard (crushing)
for the first time.
- Indistinct.
- And I said, what the fuck is this?
And he's like, this is the World Wide Web.
And I was like, I heard about that shiet.
(Tray chuckles)
And I was... For the
kids that are listening
this is how crazy internet was in 94, 95.
I waited my turn, to get on the computer
to go on AOL.
It was so crazy, this thing,
like being on the internet and
seeing people in chat rooms
that I watched it as a spectator,
while my man was on the keyboard.
And I finally like an hour later,
sat down and clicked a couple buttons
and found myself on a baseball
card bulletin board in AOL,
and about seven minutes
into my internet life,
which was this.
I said, this is gonna change my life.
Straight up, just like that.
Like straight out of a fucking movie.
And that started the
conversation in my head,
which to six months
later, saying to my dad,
"dad we need a website,
but a liquor store."
We didn't have a compute, my
dad didn't take credit cards.
Like he was old school.
I was born in the Soviet Union.
He's like cash only, doesn't trust people
like wouldn't take checks.
Doesn't believe in anybody.
Like, you know, (laughs)
like all that stuff.
And I got him there.
I just completely knew, the same...
You know, it's funny,
the one skill I really have
is my intuition about things
and people is heavy.
Like it's just really my biggest thing.
So like literally looking at the internet,
or looking at the investments I made
Facebook, Twitter, Coinbase,
or the fact that I bought Bitcoin in 2014,
is no different than me
thinking that Gunna, or Dababy
we're gonna be good.
Or that I thought Alvin Kamara
was gonna be a good player
when we started VaynerSports,
even though he was the backup,
running backup at Tennessee,
there's something in me,
that understands people,
and understands what people are gonna do.
And that's been my whole life.
Like if I was an A and
R guy, I would dominate.
If I was a scientist,
like looking at spiders,
for 20 years in the woods,
I would figure it out.
Like, that's my thing.
And so, that's what
happened with the internet.
That's how it started.
And my mission in my twenties,
I came to this country with nothing.
I was born in Russia, lived
in a studio in Queens,
with like eight family members.
Like I grew up rugged.
Like my mom was frugal,
and didn't have money.
So I was like, if I wanted Nintendo,
if I wanted stuff, I
had to buy it as a kid.
So I'd always fight for
money, and business.
And my number one goal
was to help my parents
liquor store business.
Like I gave up my twenties,
all of my twenties men.
When kids talk to me about like,
oh, duh, I'm like, I
gave up all my twenties
to build a business for my parents.
I left with zero ownership
of that business.
And I blew that business up
from three to 60 million.
And you know, sometimes
people try to rag on me
like, ah you got handed.
Shiet I'm like, you think
that's what happened?
Let me tell you the truth.
I took a business from
three to 60 million,
never got paid shiet.
'Cause in the family business,
you put all back into the business.
So it's one thing if you
make money for somebody else
in a corporation but at least you get paid
a million dollars a year.
I was getting paid 50, 60, 70,000 a year
building a big ass business.
And at 34 years old, left
and had to start my company
in somebody else's
conference room, VaynerMedia,
and buddy media's conference room
'cause I didn't have
the money to pay rent.
- And so, this is pre-social media.
So what strategies are you using
to build a company from three to 60?
Right?
'Cause I mean, internet
is just becoming a thing.
- Back then it was
email, and Google AdWords
that really took me off.
And banner ads, people used
to click banner ads, kids.
I would buy banner ads for
$500 a month on a website,
like winespectator.com and
people click that shiet.
You know, back then everyone
was curious about everything
like banners and like, oh cool.
It was kinda like cool.
You're like, oh, shiet!
It takes me somewhere else.
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
Like, you know,
again, I'm talking like
it's a hundred years ago.
It's only 25 years ago, but it's like 10.
It's a lifetime ago.
- Yes it is basically-
- There was no cell phones.
It was crazy.
There was no laptops.
Like you had to sit at a fucking
desk to be on the internet.
- This feels like a scene
in the Wreck-It Ralph movie.
Where (laughs) he's just (indistinct).
- But, so banner ads
being a little early social called forums,
remember bulletin boards
and message boards?
- Yeah.
- Well, I was part of
those, all the wine boards.
They're like, why do you know so much?
Well, I own, or my family owns,
or my dad and I run this
place called wine library
check it out, winelibrary.com.
Two clicks, five clicks,
like real like bricklaying you know.
And then I figured out email in 97.
And I was like, okay,
this is gonna be big.
And so, I just started
asking every customer
that came into the liquor
store, you got an email?
And this again, back to
the old days, 25 years ago
people were like, yeah, I got
an email it's aol@yahoo.com.
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
But it was crazy.
Luckily, the store was in Jersey
where a lot of people
worked on wall street
and the wall street cats,
had email pretty early.
And so, you know, started getting
out wall street clientele.
And that really started
changing our business.
But catalogs.
I did catalogs, direct mail, newspaper,
full-page ads in the New York
Times, and Wall Street Journal
and Star-Ledger in Jersey big shout out.
When I made a couple of bucks
and was able to put them on.
You know it was all.
Family immigrant businesses
are you don't take money out
to buy shiet.
You put it back in the
business, back in the business,
back in the business.
So one of the reasons
I never really amassed a lot
of money, during that time
was my dad wasn't paying
me or him any real money.
Every dollar was back into advertising,
back into more employees,
back, back, back.
And so we were feeding.
One of the reasons I tell
a lot entrepreneurs now
like feed your business.
You know everyone wants to be
an entrepreneur to take it out
and buy a fucking rollie, is that right?
And buy a bed and like
and buy like some...
And I'm like, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't flex yet you just started.
Put it back in, back in.
Your watch will be more expensive.
Your trip will be nicer.
Your flying commendations will be better
but you got to feed your
business for a minute.
- Yeah.
- Stay down till you come up.
So you talked about how
you left the company
and left with zero.
So you left with...
Hey, why did you leave?
So it's a family business,
you grew it, it's $60 million,
is going nicely 10X the whole situation
or 20X the whole situation.
So why did you leave?
And-
- You want some real shiet?
Three main reasons.
Resentment, my brother's
11 years younger than me,
and I love my paps.
Let me break them down for you.
'Cause you guys will go deep
here. I'm gonna give it to you.
Shiet that I don't usually talk about.
- [Rishad] Yeah.
- [Tray] Yeah.
- You work 15 hours a
day, including Saturdays.
'Cause you're in the retail business
from 22 to 32 years old.
No fun, no trips, work 15 hours a day.
Real shiet that,
and I'm like fucking like,
propaganda why are people acting
like they're working.
In the store, 8:00 AM,
leave the store 10:00 PM.
In the stores, 7:00 AM,
leave the store 11:00 PM.
for fucking 10 years?
And you take it, from 3.8 million to 60
and you have no real,
real, real money like that?
And now you're married,
and you've got a little bit of that right?
You start, being fucked up a little.
- Yeah.
- Got it? I'm just talking real to you-
(Rishad and Tray chattering)
- I was like, yo I was a kid.
Now listen, the reason I
wasn't really fucked up
and it was okay.
Was, I wanted that?
I wanted to pay my parents back.
I knew I was fucking great.
I knew it.
I knew what's going on with me right now.
And on some record, on the record shiet,
I haven't even started.
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
No, I'm being really honest with you guys.
You're gonna look at
this video in 13 years
and be like damn,
he really wasn't even
like in the same universe.
Like, I mean it, I really
feel like I'm just starting.
I'm patient.
I know life is long.
I have wisdom.
I hung out with old grandparents
all the time as a kid
and I never understood why.
And now I understand, I'm an old soul.
I was patient.
I knew I could give up my
twenties for my parents.
Feel good about that.
Feel like I really put them on.
'Cause they put me on.
Be like, you know, settle that debt,
you know what I mean.
(Rishad and Tray laughing)
- Now you even.
- Now we good.
- Now we even really, I
was a little bit like that.
I needed it for me,
but I really love my
parents on some real shiet
their the best.
I was like, fuck it.
I'm going to get mine regardless.
Let me really do something here.
But now, after a decade,
I started getting into that
little place of like (grunting),
number two my brother's
11 years younger than me.
My parents were 20 when they had me.
Like that old Russia shiet,
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
so my brother was coming up
and he didn't wanna work with my dad.
My dad's a tough,
like my dad's a different kind
of personality, old school.
And he didn't want to be about that.
And so I wanted to jam with him.
I've been teaching him
entrepreneurship since he was a kid
eBay, garage sales,
all that shiet that people know about me.
So, I really wanted to jam with him.
So we kinda decided somewhere
around his senior high school,
freshman year of college,
like we're gonna do this.
So that was in the back of my mind.
And I left when he graduated.
He graduated in may of 2009, and I left.
Started VaynerMedia, but I was doing both.
I was doing Wine Library and
VaynerMedia from 2009 to 2011.
And then number three, I love my dad.
Let me explain.
My dad was one of the guys.
He was one of the 10, 15 guys,
in the liquor business in Jersey.
He had one of the good stores.
Doing 4 million, in a liquor store
in the eighties, that's a real thing.
You know, it's different
day, different age.
There was no major players,
liquor businesses fragmented.
You don't have Walmarts
and shiet like that.
So, he was a guy, he was one of the guys.
He was one of the people that
could throw around some clout.
He was one of the bigger
buyers and he loved it.
He loved it.
I came along, and took that
shiet to the fucking moon.
So I became the guy.
And so now all of a sudden you
see where I'm going right now
the suppliers, all people.
- Yeah, yeah.
- All of a sudden my dad lost his clout.
And my dad, and I wasn't
about sharing it either
'cause I took the wheel
and was like no one person can drive.
So like go in the passenger
seat, I love you dad,
you're still my dad,
and you could always call that
once in a blue moon dad card
and make me do something
I don't want to do
but 98% of the time I'm driving.
And the first year that
I did the business,
he was renovating and
decided to build a new house
for him and my mom that
he loves construction
so they built a new house.
And that first year we went
from four to 10 million
and he kind of looked, and he's like fuck.
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
One, two, three, right?
- I love you Garry.
- And so he was like I love you
but, fuck I'm not going to mess with this.
Next year is 17, and he's like,
okay, now I got something.
And so, but what that did was,
I willing to do it for him,
but I was going to take the shine.
I was gonna have the leverage.
I was gonna be the guy.
And I loved my dad and we were
starting to have conflict.
It was pretty cool for the
first eight or nine years,
little things.
But now we were starting to
have consistent conflict.
I had my resentment up.
I become real famous in the
liquor business, the guy, guy
and nobody gave a shiet about my dad.
And I saw the pain in
his eyes and it hurt me,
'cause I love my dad and
people forgot about his part.
He came to America with no language.
He came to America with no money.
He came to America and took all the risk
and what he did from zero to what he did,
I know I'm going to the
tippy top of all time.
And I'm still gonna always admire
what he did from zero to that spot.
And I have my own zero story,
but it's different and he's my dad.
And so it just felt like the
right time if that makes sense.
- Yeah, that's a transition.
- That's an honest answer.
So when you start the media
company, I'm assuming,
so you learn early as far as emails,
and internet marketing and all of that.
So, you just transitioned that into-
- Yes on YouTube.
Up to 2006, YouTube comes out
and I'm like this is going
to be big. I hit it again.
- Why did you think
YouTube was gonna be big?
- 'Cause I thought the internet
was going to take over the world,
and here was the first thing I ever saw
that did videos proper.
That was like, this is it.
And you know, what's
beautiful about being old,
is you got the receipts.
Go to YouTube type in
Wine Library episode one,
February 21st, 2006.
When it was still independent,
Google hadn't even bought it.
I saw it, the video starts with me saying
I think this is the first
wine show on the internet.
You know what I mean like.
- I'll watched it, I'll
watched it (laughs).
- I'll appreciate it.
I saw it, I did it
and I was right.
And then YouTube sells
for 1.7 billion in 2007.
And to help everybody
here, that'd be like TikToK
selling for a trillion
to Facebook right now.
The number was crazy back then,
one seven was like (exploding)
like you didn't even think
about shiet like that.
And so, that happened.
And that's when my career really took off.
I said, wait a minute.
I was right about dot-com.
I was right about email.
I was about Google AdWords.
I was right about blogging,
even though I didn't do it.
I was right about this YouTube thing.
Maybe I'm not just a good businessman
or liquor store runner or seller.
I might be good at like just knowing shiet
that stood with the
combo I had with myself.
And I read an article that
YouTube had angel investors.
And I was like, what's an angel investor?
And I Googled it,
and I was like I'm gonna
be an angel investor.
And then the next year, I
went to South by Southwest,
'cause you gotta put yourself in it.
If you're going to be in it.
I went to Silicon Valley a bunch.
And within the year of me deciding,
that 150, I don't remember,
80 to 150K I saved,
'cause I was living in
a bullshit apartment,
never going out.
So even though I was making
50, I was saving 4,000 a year.
Making 60, saving 8,000 a year.
You see what I'm saying?
So when I tell kids with my content,
like be humble, I lived there.
I don't give advice that
I fucking read in a book.
I don't give advice that I didn't live.
So because I was living humble,
and not buying dumb shiet
even though I wasn't making
much, I had a little something.
And now I saw this opportunity,
and the first few companies I invested in
were Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr.
And it changed my life.
- So the angel conversation
is extremely interesting
'cause a lot of people might
not know you're angel investor.
So that's a perfect three
companies to invest in.
So angel invest in VC world is like,
you know people have
been around for decades
that do that with billions of dollars.
So you come even with a
couple of hundred thousand
that's not really real money in the VC.
- I was different then, like
I invested in Tumblr's B round
at $14 million valuation.
A B-round now is like 400 million.
It was a different world when I did it.
There was nobody coming at
these kids like that, back then.
Nobody believed in the internet like this.
Like I was able to talk
to Mark Zuckerberg,
to Ed Williams, to David Cart.
Like I was talking to the person.
It just wasn't that shine like it was.
It was like hip hop 85,
versus hip hop today.
- That's interesting-
- Basketball-
- So, further what round
did you get in Facebook?
- So Facebook I bought for Mark's parents.
- Wow (chuckles).
- Two years before the IPO,
because I'm confirming
with the Facebook crew
and Randy and Mark,
'cause Randy and her sister
worked at the company.
I'd flown out to speak to the company.
I would hang with them at conferences.
So one day I just got a call
from Randy saying, you know
my parents wanna sell
some of the Facebook stock
before the IPO because they
wanna move to California
and build a house,
and being near us, would
you like something?
She didn't start.
She didn't finish saying my parents,
and I already wired the money.
(Tray laughs)
'Cause I knew Facebook was gonna win.
And then Tumblr,
was one of the big
companies out of New York,
because shiet wasn't
happening in New York.
So Tumblr was out of New York,
and I noticed junior high kids
were on Tumblr in 2008, 2007.
And I was like, wait that might be next
'cause all the youngsters are on it.
And so I got on there,
and then Yahoo bought
Tumblr for a billion.
- Follow the youth.
- So as far as like,
the angel investing you
talking about the rounds,
can you explain that a little bit?
Because people hear about
round, seed round, fund round,
A round, B round, C round,
but they might not actually
know what that actually means.
- You know, a lot of people
use different terminology
for the same shiet,
but like, you know the angel
round is the initial money in.
Then usually, the first
time a company takes money,
the angel, the seed investment,
or the angel, right?
High risk, like most of my
angel investments went to zero,
but high reward.
You come in early on something,
they can get real crazy.
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
You know, I angel a
company called BarkBox,
that's about to go public.
That's going to get
interesting for me, you know.
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
You angel, you can get crazy.
So then there's the A.
Then it goes in very
simple order for everybody,
the A route it's kind
of the first real money,
five million bucks, three million bucks.
Then the B round, 10, 20 million bucks.
Then the C round, that's, you know,
when I said 10, 20 that's
how much they took in.
So they got a 100
million dollar evaluation
and they took a $20 million,
of what that person invested
is in for only 15% of the company,
that gives that nature because
it's 120 close trade for 20.
So, that's how it goes, angel A, B, C, D.
And usually by after D,
you're looking at going public or selling.
- So like a couple of
questions in regards to that.
For entrepreneurs, how should
they prepare themselves
to approach an angel investor?
Like what should they
already have in place?
Because from my understanding,
a company has to have a
certain amount of revenue,
like already in place
before they can actually get
venture capital or angel money.
Is that true or.
- No, angel money you can
get when you have nothing.
An idea.
Now that comes with privilege.
Let's be very honest here.
And I'm not even talking white privilege,
I'm talking rich privilege.
I know unlimited black, asian, trans,
you know if you're in
running money circles
you got a shot to get money on an idea.
You know, one of the
reasons I stopped investing
and I don't invest that much.
Most of my money right now
is going to sports cards,
we can get into that
before we get out of here.
- Yeah, yeah, (laughs).
- Is it's crazy now, like you can get,
you can basically say
I'm going to build this,
make a deck, go to people.
And they give you money, based
on a $4 million, $5 million,
$6 million, $7 million evaluation.
But, it's a very small group of people
that have access to that capital, right?
And they usually run from high university,
Stanford, Harvard, right?
Or they run in very rich circles.
Your mom and dad have wealth and you know
their friends happy to
write you a $250,000 check
at that evaluation, then you
use that to get another person.
So, you don't need to be making money.
And ironically in technology,
it's almost better that you're not.
People like to invest more in the idea,
once you start making money,
they have something to judge you on.
It's a crazy system and I'm not...
That concerns me and which
is why I've been hesitant
to go hard in an early stage.
I like it a little bit later,
where people prove it a little now.
No reason to take that risk.
So I'm more of an A and B
guy, if I really get excited.
- So when you'd actually
are gonna go after a company
or decide to invest it, is
that why you created VaynerX?
Or is that something different, right?
Because that became a holding company
at a certain point, right?
- VaynerX is different.
So I did angel investing
and went real well,
then I got hooked up with Steve Ross,
the owner, Miami Dolphins.
And he bought a piece of VaynerMedia
which was the first company VaynerMedia,
which later became VaynerX when
I started adding companies.
So I needed a holding
company for the companies.
- Okay.
- I'll get to that in a minute.
When Steve Ross invested in Vayner,
bought a piece excuse me, at VaynerMedia,
he also put up the money for a fund
and I deployed $25 million out of a fund.
As like a fund.
So everyone listening,
because we're doing some
real good educating here.
That means, that I got,
I normally get paid 2% of
the number to manage it
but because I didn't take that from him
because he already bought
a piece of my company
and we're kind of being homies,
but I got 20% of the back end.
So 20% of all the earnings.
So the 25 goes, and I get
20% of anything that happens.
So I don't put up the money.
I make the decisions,
but that gives me 20 cents
on a dollar he gets 80 cents.
And with that company, I made
a lot of smart investments.
I started a company with that money
called Resy, R-E-S-Y.
Anybody who's into
restaurants, the Resy App,
That was me.
We sold that company for nine
figures to AMX 18 months ago.
I invested in Snapchat,
Pinterest, Coinbase.
So we did real well.
- So, you talked about
the holding companies.
Why is that?
Why is that important?
- That's important because I
had VaynerMedia one company,
and then I wanted to buy a
new company called PureWow.
PureWow is a women's lifestyle
brand, dot-com publisher,
similar to Refinery29 or Bustle.
You know, I just stood up a
men's brand called One37pm
that everybody should check out.
That's more like complex advice.
So when I bought that company,
I didn't wanna put it into VaynerMedia.
'Cause it was a different kind of company,
different taxes, different all that.
So I created a holding
company called VaynerX.
One side of it was VaynerMedia,
another side was what we
call the gallery media group
which held PureWow in it.
Then we started One37pm.
Then I started going ham.
I started a new company
called Sasha Group,
after my dad Sasha to be
VaynerMedia for small businesses.
Then I started a speaking
bureau, VaynerSpeakers.
Then I started a company for
e-commerce VaynerCommerce.
You know, I just started going.
So I've got a series of businesses now.
We just set up a new
company called VaynerTalent,
where we help people
build a personal brand
and we represent and manage some people.
So now I got my holding code
and the way you do that,
the reason I sit at the
top of the holding code,
I'm the active CEO of VaynerMedia,
but I got people running
the other companies,
and you create incentive
plans for them at their level.
It all ladders up to the big level.
And that's where I'm at.
- There you have it.
So as far as, one last
question about the angel.
What do you look for?
'Cause you obviously
had a bunch of success,
Facebook, Twitter, Tumblr,
Uber, Snap, Venmo to name a few.
So it's not luck.
So you obviously have an eye for talent,
more so than I mean a gut feeling, yeah.
But do you have anything that you like,
a checklist where you look for.
- A hundred percent.
Two things.
My conviction of what's going on in life,
and then the person.
So I call it the jockey and the horse.
I gotta pick the horse.
Let me give you one
right now for everybody.
I'm gonna make some
people some money today.
NFT.
NFT stands for non-fungible tokens,
crypto art, right-
- We've already got a
conversation about it.
- So this is common, I believe in it.
There's gonna be a lot of money lost.
So don't go crazy,
everyone who's listening.
Spend a hundred hours,
let me say it slowly,
so it sinks in everyone's head.
A hundred hours,
a hundred hours of education.
Then maybe you go buy
a piece of crypto art.
But I now believe in NFT.
I really believe in it.
Now I've got to go find
people that I believe in
that can ride that horse.
So I make a decision on the horse,
but then I got to believe in the jockey.
I lost a lot of money.
My first round, 2007,
eight, nine, 10, 11, 12,
because I was right about the concept.
But I was wrong about the person's stomach
who was running it.
She or he couldn't take a punch.
You understand?
- Yeah.
- That's what I'm looking for now.
Who can take a punch?
That's what entrepreneurship is.
Entrepreneurship is UFC.
Entrepreneurship is boxing,
who can take a punch.
So I'm right about a lot
of stuff to your point.
I've got a great career on that.
But now what I'm spending more
time on is, can she do it?
Is he about that life?
And then I'm trying to
spend more time on that.
And I think I've done better lately.
- Yeah.
- So, I mean,
I've watched the videos, men.
And like you said, they're all receipts.
So, creating and finding
global trends is your thing.
I watched it when you said that Facebook
is gonna be sold to IG, in 2011.
I saw it when you said-
- IG, sold to the Facebook-
- I mean, Facebook sold it, yeah.
And then the Joe Rogan to Spotify.
And so, is NFT the next thing,
or there's something, yo that was crazy.
Is there something else?
- NFT, is gonna happen.
Something else, I'm about audio.
I've talked about that a lot.
Now you see clubs, I'm
getting a lot of love.
Again, because of Clubhouse,
I was about audio.
I kept yelling, audio, audio, audio.
Premium sports cars, (laughs)
LeBron, Kobe, Jordan.
NFT.
NFT, I feel is really solidified on.
- That's great, who had that conversation?
- We had the...
So somebody texts us, one
of our patreon members
text me about the digital
art, in that space
and then we had it with 19 keys.
- Oh yeah.
- She said the same thing.
- Yeah, he was explaining,
he was in Miami.
We sat down with a good friend
of ours and he was explaining
this to us about crypto and digital art.
And I didn't really understand it.
He took like a half an hour,
and he was like, if you
have like an art showing
and it's like the artists
like leases out the image
for just that-
- In the virtual world.
- Yeah, it was a whole thing.
And that's the first time
and it's crazy that you mentioned that
because that's the first
time I ever heard of
it last week, and now
you bringing it up again.
- Let me bring up something else
that's going to make it work.
The other thing I was
going to answer you on,
in combination with crypto art,
like call it an NFT, Non-fungible token.
So like digital art, crypto art, is VR.
So look, we're basically in VR now.
Think about what,
everybody take a step back.
I'm going to make it real common sense.
How much time are you in your phone?
Think about how many minutes a day
you're looking at your phone.
There could be a rhinoceros behind you,
and you have no idea.
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
So,
the jump step to Oculus, right?
AKA I'm predicting in 10, 15 years
you're not going to need some
big ass thing on your eyes.
You're going to be
contact lensed and then.
If we live in a virtual
world, six hours a day
which I predict will happen to everybody
who's listening here.
Now, I think that's 10, 15, 20.
But I'm patient.
If we live virtually,
you have understand why
blockchain, crypto, NFTs matter
because you can prove that you own it.
It's on the blockchain,
it's on the ledger.
So you're the only one with it.
Now, imagine if you're the only one in it.
If you imagine blockchain
integration of VR
and somebody is coming to your pad,
and you're like living it,
like it's going to feel like we're living.
And the same reason people flex art,
you see where this is going?
- Yeah.
- Can we go back to the collectible cards?
'Cause I know that, I
mean, that's your origin.
So this must feel like surreal.
Like, yo, this is coming back.
- The biggest reason so many
of my friends, my brother,
my best friends didn't
believe me three years ago,
is I think they thought I
was thinking with my heart.
Got it?
- Yeah, cause I mean,
that was the beginning-
- When I was like, why
is nobody believing me
three years ago?
When I was like, yo, I got
receipts now, listen to me.
And I was like, oh, shiet,
the people that believed in me the most,
that love me the most,
that know me the most,
they think I'm in love.
'Cause you're right, it is my first love.
That's like cards in 1987
to 1993,
that's when I became Gary Vee.
Like, what I'm built on today,
is those six years of
doing sports card shows,
being with grown-ass men and winning.
- So-
- As a child.
- Yeah, I remember that.
I'm gonna let you go.
But I remember being
that kid from like 91,
I was collecting baseball
cards, and basketball cards,
and marvel cards. And I was
like, I gotta save these.
I think the most valuable
one I could think we had
was a Ken Griffey Jr. rookie card,
and I'm like, I'm holding this forever.
- That was like-
- I still have it, it's worth it's like,
I think it's mint nine
or something like that.
It might be worth like six, $700.
But I'm like, I'm keeping this forever.
- So what's the deal with
this new virtual wave
that you're speaking of
which I'm not familiar with
this whole situation.
So what is this.
Virtual cards?
- No, like the trading
cards, like baseball cards.
- I know, but like, it is
like a new age of that,
'cause it's like the future-
- Well there is something,
there is two things bruin.
There's NBA top shop, I don't
know if you've seen that.
but that's-
- Oh, I think I did yeah,
they like the holograms
- Well they're like
highlights on the blockchain.
We're talking a little bit now on NFT
the shiet we were talking about earlier.
NBA top shops huge.
Then there's a soccer, one
proper football coach so rare
built on top of Ethereum, okay?
And that's a word people
starting to hear now, right?
'Cause that's different than Bitcoin.
But the other thing that has
hit, because it's a platform
that people build on top of like so rare.
So,
yeah, there's a little bit of that bruin,
but yeah, the sports card thing
three years ago, I saw it.
I'm like, this is next.
This is next.
And you know, again, like I said earlier,
Charli D'Amelio, Sports cards,
Uber, Gunna, Little keyed,
you know, Snapchat, like it's
all the same game for me.
What do I see that nobody else
sees as easily as I see it.
I always ask myself, am I tricking myself.
So I double check, I triple
check, I quadruple check.
And the receipts are there.
The YouTube videos of
me and Charli D'Amelio
before she went, there.
The videos of me and
Keyed and Gunna, there.
They're there.
- So your social media
acumen is highly respected.
One of the best ever doing social media.
So talking about the next
phase, where are we at next?
Obviously Clubhouse, TikToK.
How do you feel like,
do you feel cause I think
Facebook just announced something
that they're going to do something similar
to what Clubhouse has going on.
Is it here to stay or is it the next vine?
- It's Snapchat, let me explain.
Clubhouse is Snapchat.
Snapchat's still here.
I remember I was like, it's dead.
I'm like, it's not dead, it got dented.
Instagram gave it a punch.
You know, it took a hell
it might've lost it,
it definitely fell down.
- Standing in, standing in.
- Yeah at least it's standing in,
and probably lost that fight for a minute,
but it's come back,
you know, the rematch,
it always matters right?
And snap is doing quite well,
they're building a really nice company.
But Instagram took off
even more because of it.
So,
stories became a format, not just an app.
Got it?
So now you have Snap doing
well, but every platform
Twitter, LinkedIn, YouTube,
Facebook, Instagram has stories.
I think the same thing's going
to happen with Clubhouse.
Clubhouse is gonna continue
to innovate and do its thing.
But I believe that every single platform,
Facebook, Instagram, LinkedIn, Twitter
are all gonna have,
clubhouse-like dynamics in it.
And it's gonna be a feature
in the biggest platforms in the world.
- So, can Clubhouse survive?
'Cause we saw this with Vine,
when they had the eight second clip
and then Instagram came and took it.
- No, that's just not, you
know that's where people
get their history wrong.
Vine won.
Let me explain it.
Vine sold their company to Twitter.
Vine died because the guys left.
Vine didn't have to die.
Vine took the bag.
- That's a win.
- Of course they can look at Snap.
Snap's just fine.
At all-time highs on it's stock.
- Yeah, the stock
I was just about to say
the stock is going well.
- Yeah.
- So yes, men of course Clubhouse can.
Now, Snap was probably further along
when that feature happened on Instagram.
So what Clubhouse has to worry about
is if all these companies come at them
from all different directions,
can they continue to grow or
will people do what happened.
I'm sure you remember this
when Instagram did that thing,
everyone's like, oh good, I
don't have to be on Snapchat
'cause they're insecure,
because they only had a
thousand followers then.
And had a million over here.
Like everyone's on their insecure shiet
but I was staying on both
because attention is attention.
So you know right now people are insecure.
They are not even in Clubhouse.
They don't have an invite.
So when Twitter pops it up,
or Instagram pops it up,
they're like, yeah, you know what I mean?
I don't have to go there.
I'm not behind.
So that's what Clubhouse
has to worry about.
- What about TikTok?
- TikToK is a beast.
TikTok has,
is just on fire.
I think people are completely
confused what's going on.
If you're under 25, it's
TikToK, comma, Instagram,
and it's not even close.
TikToK will be interesting.
There's so about their
world, their algorithm,
finding creativity.
If you ask me which platform's
most likely not to do audio
like that,
I would say it's TikToK and Snap.
I don't see a shot that
LinkedIn, YouTube, and Facebook,
and Instagram don't do it.
Twitter's already done it.
- Yeah.
- It's interesting because
it's like for entrepreneurs,
you get comfortable with one platform
and then another platform comes out
and it's like you're spinning
in all different directions.
So what's your advice
for people that may not
have a budget to hire, a whole staff.
And it's like, they
just focus on one thing.
They got Instagram figured out
and now they kind of like you said,
they built a nice following on Instagram
and they feel like they got
to start at zero on TikToK
or zero on Clubhouse.
- Multiple things.
One, crying about it ain't gonna do shiet.
That's the game.
Sorry.
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
Like, you know people had
MTV and BET figured out
and Napster came along and
fucked up their game, right?
Shiet happens.
Sorry.
If you're an entrepreneur,
you're in the business of
getting punched in the face.
Nobody owes you anything.
So that's number one,
that's what I tell him.
Number two, you don't start at zero
if you got a million
followers on Instagram
you post a little photo,
I may be on clubhouse at 8:00 PM.
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
You know what I mean?
So you're not starting at zero,
your audience is moving with you.
I got half a million followers
already on Clubhouse.
I've barely been on it
cause I've been busy.
You know what I mean?
You don't start at zero.
Your equity travels.
- Yeah.
Can I talk about one of my favorite quotes
is you've said it's the empty the bucket
and it's true in relationships.
And it was like, I was living that.
I was like, it's tough to be in a marriage
where you have something on
your mind that you fester
because after a while
the bucket overflows.
But can you talk about the
importance of that in business
of emptying the bucket.
- It's life resentments are problem.
And for me, I can deal with it.
I can eat shiet.
I can fill that bucket.
'Cause I'm a big picture, I'm empathetic.
But even for me, it tips over
and for my dad, he was the
reverse. I always said to my dad,
"dad, your bucket is the size of this cup,
"my bucket is the size of the ocean
"that's where you and I are different."
He would get triggered quick.
And for me I would just
eat shiet, eat shiet.
It was even my leverage.
You know,
but like the reality is candor matters.
Now I like kind candor.
If you're gonna tell somebody the truth,
deliver it with some compassion,
not like, yo you stink.
You know what I mean?
Like you gotta think that through,
but yeah you have to be
careful of resentment.
You have to be careful
of holding shiet in,
'cause it's not sustainable
that shiet's gonna come out.
Either in you're doing bad behavior,
alcohol, humans need
escape from unhappiness.
And so you got to get
shiet off your chest.
And so I think a lot about that,
and I've historically
not been great at it.
I've been lucky because
my buckets and ocean
but even the ocean overflows at times
and those have not been
good events in my life
and I'm trying to stay away from that.
And so I'm trying to empty it
more often and emptying it.
Emptying the bucket means
go and have kind candor
and talk shiet out.
Communication, heals
everything, even the hard talks.
And when you're most upset,
you have to be most
compassionate to the other side
not the other way around.
'Cause you'll becoming hot,
they're gonna react hot
and the next thing you know,
you come to blows whether
physically or verbally
and that's never a good thing.
- The ocean becomes a tsunami.
- Yeah, exactly.
(Tray laughs)
- One last before we wrap
under-priced attention
I know you're big on
obviously social media
but for entrepreneur,
is that the only way to
get under-priced attention
these days?
Or are there other hacks
that business owners,
entrepreneurs, creatives, can
go about to get their brand
out there and the name out there?
- The internet is under-priced attention,
or doing like a stunt, right?
Like if you like paint
a street or something
or like, you know, like
you got to do something
like shocks the world in real life.
- Go viral.
- Go viral, but that's hard.
It's hard, hard.
Whereas on the internet,
LinkedIn's organic reach
is through the roof.
TikTok's organic...
You can be nobody, quote
unquote, no audience,
make one TikTok the first one and go off.
How do you not take advantage of that?
Clubhouse right now.
How do you not go on?
If you're trying to build an audience
you should be living on Clubhouse.
People just looking for rooms
and new people to follow.
So yeah, the internet and social networks
especially are the spot.
But it's the content you put into it.
That's contextual.
- Yeah, it's all about content.
- Content is king and it's cash.
- That content is cash
and king (Tray laughs).
Gary, it's been a pleasure brother.
- You know what?
This has been long overdue.
Two years ago, we ran into
you, at the K-Swiss booth.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And we said, look-
- Remember that
- I remember, are you kidding me?
And you know how much
pressure I've been feeling
about this interview.
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
It was documenting your
fan base, of harassing me.
I feel guilty and shiet,
'cause I fuck with you guys.
And I'm just trying to
balance my life out here
am busy as shiet.
And like, and then you
know, like the way life
actually works,
you end up doing somebody
else's thing before.
Like I just met last week
and I still know in the back of my head,
I got these two good looking dudes
that I got to do with this with.
And so like, I'm fucking happy as shiet
we finally did this thing.
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
- Yeah, I put it on
Instagram, It was like 10,000-
- A man of his word.
- I'm like tag them.
- Yeah.
- We did this men, I'm
cheering for you guys,
it's been fun to watch from a far.
You continue to build bricks
over these last two years.
I cheer for you heavy.
If I can ever get you
somebody you can't get to.
I'm a DM away.
And I hope you have a
great, great, great, 2021.
- I appreciate that brother.
- I appreciate men.
- And shout out to Charlemagne,
for connecting the dots on it to
- Yeah.
Shock the god put the
final piece in there.
- Yeah.
- No problem.
Yeah, men.
But yeah, you are a man of your word then
and I'm so happy that we got it done.
And we're neighbors on the charts too.
So it makes perfect sense.
- Am sure you guys are doing real work,
I'm really proud of that.
That little humble brag you just put out.
It's real, I'm proud of you guys.
You're doing real work.
It's brick by brick.
Listen, I did Wine
Library TV for 18 months.
Nobody knew who the fuck I was.
I told you guys earlier in 13 years,
50,000 times more people
are gonna know who I am.
I'm just starting to
we're all on our journey.
And it's the journey, it's the bricks.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, for sure.
- Yeah.
- Like I swear to god, you
might not believe this.
I don't know my numbers.
I don't know where I am in the charts.
It just, you know, like
I'm just so tunneled back
to the horse and the jockey,
you know, those horses
they put the blinders on the sides.
Like, I don't know where I rank.
I don't know where it is.
I don't, you know,
people trying to goad me
into the shiet all the time.
I'm just focused.
I'm in my cocoon.
I'm in my silence.
I'm in my zone.
I'm just putting in work in the dirty.
I'm not at the equinox.
I'm in a dirty gym that smells like shiet
getting in my reps.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, that's it.
- Yeah,
that's it's like that Rocky vibe.
- A hundred percent.
- Cutting down trees.
- We be getting caught in that.
Like people like, oh, you
guys are doing so great.
And we're just like, looking
ahead to what's coming,
like yo, we gotta stay focused.
- I tell my friends all
the time don't get fancy
until it's time to get fancy.
Whoever holds their
breath, the longest wins.
- Ooh, that's a bar.
- Bar's out here, baby.
(Rishad and Tray laugh)
- Gary, I appreciate you brother.
(logo thudding)
- YouTube watcher,
what's up it's Gary Vee,
first of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you please subscribe,
because my commitment and
exploration of YouTube
is about to explode stories,
polls, more content,
more engagement, more
surprise and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.